I don't know if you went to college yeah
I went to the University in Canada hold
on mm-hmm they what I went to the
University of Canada is there a unit is
there such a thing Canada I'm sure they
have a website I didn't have a website
when I was there was sort of before
timber it says colleges universities so
here we are study in Canada top
universities cities we said University
of Canada what is the best University
and says Canada right there nobody in
Canada yeah but you said you went to the
University of Kent yeah but sometimes
they just call it Canada for short
no no because yeah Canada hey where'd
you go to school I was at the camp not
in the library
no I went to the University of Canada
where I majored in psychology man you
are I think you got caught in the line
you lying dude I don't lie that's one of
the Canadian traits we learn in the
Canadian College of Connect I said
you're stumbling over your words cuz
everybody down here in the United States
of America is always like oh you
Canadians you don't know anything
ha ha ha oh whatever the case we can get
into the details of it but it's not
important but what is important is that
as you notice as Bryan became
impassioned about what he was speaking
on yeah
he sat like a chimp that's right and
that's a no Punk delay i'm i sat like a
monk no you sitting like a chimp you
don't call me a [ __ ] your tutors sitting
like my muscularity who's trying to find
a way to suck man you're ruining at you
you brought this down the level of a
you've brought this down to the gutter a
chimp who's who's sitting on a slope
rock and thinks maybe now I can and he
pulled out your teeth and he goes to his
balls and he's like if I pull my balls
you know I know that they're called
balls and he starts pulling so that is
our dance is not a side story towards
his mouth but then his finger goes into
his [ __ ] and then it goes oh you head
does it and then this is just the rest
born in heat but then you have to start
talking about so I agree with you though
Bryan Callen did Tom Green yeah yeah me
and my hair yeah dude that's you wonder
why every girl likes me
it's yeah that's back when you were like
they were like 51 I'm making a very
interesting funny point and look I'm
sunkissed man that's me a little bit
lighter than I am now see your [ __ ]
son now mom and I really feel like I
should take off all my clothes right now
to prove how good I look naked no my
girlfriend will attest to it even Ryan
you've seen me naked look at me with my
shirt off there we're all right yeah
that's the old ham fat or one Studios
that's a have in the bottom of my house
and brought and it looks like Chris has
a jar of pickles and he's just eating
but he does have a jar he's eating that
looks like chocolate cake and a jar of
pickles yeah that Chrissy Chris
chocolate cake in a jar well Chris does
if it's not in food you know Krishna and
food yes no no no Chris doesn't eat
anything good he doesn't got a nice
restaurant sir what a difference he sits
that around where but he'd said [ __ ]
different diets at Vons he's a diner guy
well that's where you get a mustard
sandwich with a side of Turkey that's
right which is what he he's a mustard
sandwich with Weird Al and sends me and
Chris D'Elia and Marshall cook pictures
of his penis we've seen that yeah I've
seen pictures actually one of the
funniest things you've done on on text
one of the more daring video I don't
know yeah you can say any more seconds
Brian one day Brian one day bright sends
a text that Chris and her other pal
Marshall cook and he's like hey guys
what's up I'm in Minnesota probably
where you don't know because you're
always a Minnesota no no it's a
wonderful place
say Brad cuz that's where I'll be this
weekend I'm in Korea I'm an awful room
in Brea which I wouldn't be an O dome
because I live nearby so your suggestion
doesn't work
he was in a hotel room and he's like hey
guys I'm just I'm on the road and rah
rah rah and I just want to go geez guys
there's a rat in here there's a rat of
it and it's like a selfie video and it's
shaking around he's like I got it I got
it okay I got it I got and like four I
was really like what where is this going
and he's I got it dad see I gotcha
gotcha a little and then he takes the
camera he pans down and he has his his
his bits his squeezed hard huh twisted
around your fingers and Knuckles he just
grabbed a handful of his self both thing
all of the stuff and he had it wrapped
up and twisted red I got you just uh
just a fleshy pink to red yeah handful
and that was very funny Brian thanks a
bunch across the street I was watching
these some gay dude sat down at the bar
next to me yeah I know the guy with the
toupee the worst to pay for ever seen
your life oh my god it's a very strange
thing it's a very nice person he's such
a sign nice and such a good-looking guy
and like yeah I'm here anyway I'm not
searching thank you very we're very
where you think it's a comb-over
I can't it's so figura terrible yeah
there's no way you went to a wig store
and bought that yeah and then put it on
I was like yeah they are throw with this
you have any hairstyle yeah I I'm it's
one of the more incredible things I've
ever seen you should ask him about it
yeah you said you go look and I go oh
that's that's the most it might be the
most incredible thing I've ever since
right it's insane hairpiece very like
like yeah like came out three do you
want it so avatar on three me I was like
this is amazing and his hair is same is
the same it's hard right when you see
like oh hell yeah there he is yeah I'm
always amazed that people do that it was
got to get picture of them right it
looks very Trump you know you you are
what came fasted for that role didn't
now did he fast for months look he
fasted for I believe three months you
[ __ ] up am i when you see his body and
he's obviously has a horrible eating
disorder I guess yeah god he looks good
Mayura goes but the [ __ ] we're only
doing it because you
yes so Arvin skinny headed you want to
be a bird I can do it
a little physical I would die no you
could never do it you're too big you pet
you fasted for 72 hours
well that was the plan because I was
working out and then this Jocko video
popped up right he's just like things
suggested and Jaya who I loved shudder
to Jocko and a video popped up and he's
talking about fasting he was like
someone asked him a question on his
podcast he's talking about fasting yes
you know I did send me to our it's not a
big deal you know after first freaking
few hours I drink some water then you
realize how dependent you on food and
reset your system and he's like everyone
makes a big deal about it's not a big
deal I thought it's not a big deal I'm
gonna do that it's not a big deal at all
yeah that's [ __ ] easy I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna do it so I said a picture you
and Chris went look who just started
saying to our fat Chris she goes mmm
well let's not do that let's [ __ ] eat
I lasted till about 8:00 p.m. that night
yeah big man got hungry yeah go faint
our eyes did well the problem is I'm run
around my kid all day Ozzy aunt is yeah
well if you're gonna fast you should do
a little lemon juice with some honey you
can't have funny can you do a new coffee
people syrup and well no no you tell my
sugars bro you can't do coffee with a
little cream nope black coffee you new
black coffee
now some people just you serve two hours
fast with just water it's a handsome guy
there were like look at this look at
show he'd be like if you if you're
making us like a [ __ ] if you're
making a comic book and you drew a
marine or are you guys come on oh is
that yes no no what is that big and that
the metal gear solid guy what are you
doing that's [ __ ] give my patch think
familiar solid yeah he's years of war
what are we doing one of those guys dear
listeners podcasting look at his face
you're listening to podcast no he just
he's so tough
he's just so tough yeah everything I
know like the questions I got what are
you talking about even just you're like
oh god always looks like he's in just a
bad mood look at his eyes but he's super
friendly you know he's a black belt in
jujitsu as well right I'm sure I'm sure
look at him legit black belt like really
good legit like yeah
yeah I have no watched I watched a
documentary Woodstock and one of the
things I thought was it's fun yeah one
of the things I noticed was that was
1969 and one of the things I noticed was
literally literally everyone no one shot
no it's fat rugs a lot of drugs but
literally back then no there was no
obesity profit American there's none
what happened
processed food yeah processed food
that's sugar sugar sugar sure processed
food Oh sugar I guess and then also like
the the food administration and their
their agendas and yeah the food the pot
remember the pie charts every school had
mmm carbs number one and here the sugars
and breads so people just hate sensibly
there wasn't there's all in propaganda
like it was all a push towards yeah
there wasn't a whole lot of yeah but
here we get Woodstock yeah you're right
and everyone was a [ __ ] B everyone
was a [ __ ] everybody was a father
little creates post pill you just took
off [ __ ] if you got syphilis you just
took an injection there's nothing like
Woodstock is there no God man that was
when times were they well worked that
their parents had been in World War two
it was still a fresh memory Vietnam was
raging drugs with the drugs were
Jonathan music was still a draft music
was poppin him get people were fighting
for the independence their freedom just
wanted a voice yeah then the music was
doing it I mean in action rock and roll
was new drugs yet Rolling Stones popping
you got Jimi Hendrix Rolling Stones
Janis Joplin Mamas and Papas you got you
got a rocket arrest the hippie culture
was starting to form and hate ass rock
and rolling on a side what's funny you
know that Beatles were going so say so
you remember about this the Beatles they
heard about the hippie movement going on
Haight Ashbury
they flew over there got out of their
tour bus looked around experienced for a
little bit this is no movement that's
just bunch of young kids on drugs yeah
that's the thing
insane a movement got backed on the
Poynting and bounced I bet there's also
a time when psychedelics were big
oh that's living brother never done them
but that mushrooms LSD the doors
Jim Morrison My Goddess
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a guess it's a gift
it's a gift